Alex has got any apologies we've
received
sorry because I apologies
thank you
minutes of the last meeting held on the
26th of June they agreed to correct
record thank you and any Declarations of
interest you know on any of the items on
the agenda
no thank you I've not been notified of
any questions from a public so I assume
we have received any Alex that's correct
thank you
first item on the agenda is an agency
spent according to us introducing this
item I'm actually going to talk to the
item as well
um chair so that's okay
um I think this report comes here every
time it's the quarter one agency
standing board which covers the period
in April to June this year
and I think we've talked a lot about the
usage of agency workers
period of time as well and I think it's
fair to say at this point I would want
to reiterate that we only use agency
workers as a last resort and it's
usually in those Services where we need
to ensure that our statutory obligations
continue to be met
and to ensure that Services can be
delivered in some cases to our most
horrible residents and and to Children
um I think as shared in the report
Although our ratings you spend is
probably higher than where we would want
it to be and I think we again we have
several conversations over the years
about about that
um we're not the highest paying local
Authority in Greater Manchester and
thinking of the report it does say that
from the list of 17 councils they're
about 80k substantially long and that
said I think it's it will they also want
to make the point that it does remain
priority that would keep a close eye on
the spending in this space
um and we only approve agency resources
where there is an absolute need to do so
myself in a direct Finance meet every
week and we review all resources
requirements
seven
I'll just say a little bit about what's
in the report so total agency spend is
at 1.5
um all met from relative existing stuff
with gyms LED Services you'll be not
surprised to see uh in the children's
and adults directors
um in children's services this time
there is a site increase
compared to the last quality that we
reported on what's for
um and I guess we're in the starting
point of some holidays so you know there
is probably expectations that we would
see a slight increase over this this
period of time
so I think again we've already
documented
um a lot the national picture with
social work resourcing here many times
and the demand for agency workers
continues to put additional pressure in
the system and it drives up costs not
just in traffic but regionally and then
nationally
so I wanted to just update you on a
progress of an initiative that's
starting to take shape across base
Manchester
called the brains Manchester Social Work
pledge and this is about putting in
place a cap a limit on the Payway of
social workers and advanced
practitioners and team managers so that
across the greatest managed
accommodation we will all have a
consistent pay rate that we all sign up
and pay
so it's led by colleagues in the
greatest Manchester combined Authority
and the pay rate position is being
formed by usage and the data analysis
unfortunately at this stage Trafford has
held its nerve and we are probably one
of the lowest paying authorities at the
moment with respect
rates
so there is an ongoing debate
colleagues at the moment around where
that pay rate is actually going to land
so we've not got there yet we're almost
there and Trafford is playing really key
part in that debate and as you can
imagine because we are
Keen that the the introduction of the
great Spanish to Social Work pledge
doesn't mean driving up costs method so
I'll keep you posted on what happens in
that space
um over the next few months and
hopefully by December I'll have a more
comprehensive update of where that going
to Manchester social work plan to pay
position has arrived up
final decisions on the song that will be
made by Chief Executives and directors
of children's services but uh I think
you know it's important that we feed
into that discussion um in that way
Okay so
some good news in adults director the
agency usage has decreased
um and I think you know legal and
governance is a report on the agenda
um today around introducing the market
pay supplement so I think it's fair to
say that the spending in legal and
government is Arena at the moment has
increased and that's about making sure
that we've got the ability to recruit
and retain qualified lawyers which is so
important so we have seen an increase in
that part of the the organization
site increases in place directorate and
strategy resources but I'm going to end
on a positive note because we've seen a
reduction in finance and systems so
again I think what I would say
um employment committee have asked to
note the contents that we call that we
continue to have a rigorous monitoring
approach to the use of agency staff we
only use them if there is an absolute
need to
um and myself and the Director of
Finance week weekly to ensure that that
robust thickness clearance process
continues to
student operates
okay
thanks Andrew does anybody have any
questions on this report
councilman and counselor harambe for
godson call Brook broad I was just
wondering
um
it's it's a it's a great report and it's
really good to see the the in that the
project is moving forward with the um
social care Austrian I'm really pleased
to see that I was just going to ask you
do you know when you report on the
agency spent it's like actual numbers
which I I understand why it is but would
we be able to say the overall Council
budget of that as a percentage available
because obviously Manchester Council
significantly bigger than us and it's
just difficult to see what that means in
terms of like how much you're spending
on average when it's just stood on the
boat
that's like 48 and pretty much like what
we did last time I can send out some
information to you all so you can start
to build a pet shop offline and what the
percentage pay position looks like in
comparison
thank you
[Music]
hi thank you for the report I just have
a quick question related to what my
colleague has asked so you know I can
see and as you mentioned that the
Reliance on the agency worker has been
produced which is sort of effectively
reducing the spend
um how does you know your department
plan for the next quarter that you know
what sort of number of stocks would be
required requiring for that quarter of
moving forward and second related
question is that
you allowed or are you also planning to
rely on another source for your own
staff recruitment sort of to rely on you
know the agency workers right
thanks thank you so I'll answer the
second point
I guess
it's rely on read since we have a
umbrella arrangement we read who you are
about this point of contact
so if we can't resource
um any staff through that umbrella
arrangement we do have certain other
arrangements with other agencies so we
would invite those in to supplement the
offer from the umbrella organization
that's in place we we read agencies so
yes absolutely and and you know for
those specialist technical roles we tend
to operate a wider variety of
agencies in in that case
I think in in planning for Quarter Two
and in fact planning which is in general
purposes I think
there's lots of strategies in place that
we're working with different services
and across the organization you know we
continue to have conversations with
agency staff to let them know the
benefits of working in a permanent
permanent contract with an organization
you know there is so much
opportunities to convert into a
permanent contracts I think you know the
that is one area where those
conversations have been had on on a
regular basis
I think we are also regularly having
different approaches to our recruitment
um you know we've tried a number of
different things we've got an event in a
couple of weeks time where our senior
leadership team hold conversations
online and with those people who might
be interested in in coming to work and
Trafford we hold face-to-face events
um you know there's a number of
different avenues that were consistently
exploring in an attempt to entice people
to work for Trafford on a more of a
permanent basis I think at the moment
especially in the children's social work
and adult social work Arena The
Temptations
this pay weights that are available
across way to Manchester a couple
probably use the pull for people to
continue to work in an agency situation
and that's why I view the cap that we're
introducing will help stabilize that
position it's not going to stop it full
stop I think there is some work to do
but it will certainly be a platform for
us to kind of continue to work
collaborative way to drive
costs and political temporary resourcing
down I think the other
initiative that's kind of emerging as a
result of some of the work that we're
doing across greater Manchester is Led
in some case advice into Trade union
colleagues is around
our permanent Workforce as well
recognizing that you know again we have
a Rangers Market factors in place to
recognize that the changes they pay that
we've seen over the years I think there
is something that perhaps we need to do
to recognize the value of the role
because I think and I may have said this
last time as well we haven't actually
reviewed the role probably for 12 years
since we're into harmonization
exercising around about
2009 10. so I think there's a lot of
different strands to this
um
difficult because you know we're not
working alone we're working with
cooperation and add some types that
takes that takes and more time than we'd
like but I think it's all in the right
direction it's definitely where we need
to be
um but I do think you know in terms of
strengthening our employment offer I
think you know it's one of the things
that we we know that we we need to
continue to promote to get you know the
message across around the benefits of
working for such a great organizations
[Music]
what's vertical about you know all of
the benefits the benefits they've been
working can in Trafford so
um hopefully thank you
counseling Leslie from Hayward
um yeah I think my first bit ties in
we've got counselor Hornby said I think
which was trying to understand because
if we're one of the lower payers in
terms of her salary permanence that just
actually then being shopping more
imbalance of the temporary step the
temporary agency staff and actually if
we paid a higher salary rate we might
actually have more success at recruiting
so that's one aspect one aspects in
terms of balance and you also is it uh
is social work mainly female dominate
amongst that most about stuff feel like
because I was looking at some of the
work of being doing sort of lighting as
it to build build Staffing into and
recruit stats in when the Salient
housing in Borough rarely so like
working with the schools and things like
that but oh it's wondered about some of
the work to actually encourage boys more
into it rather than collect as
effectively now dominated
as part of the offline and you know data
I'll do certainly kind of
um analysis on the
makeup of of the workforce
um as well
um in terms of where we are as a payer
in Greater Manchester kind of middle
um supplemented as I say by by a market
supplements so I think connected to what
we're doing around 10 we also need to
address
[Music]
to ensure that we have the richness of
the you know the resource base to
deliver and really key essential
Services across you know our most
vulnerable
yeah because the fact that we're
actually looking at the markets or
something later on in the agenda this
year's that's that's not there's no
certainty with that just as there are as
opposed to it being actually a formal
part of their salary it's it's something
that's continuously under review isn't
it
come to the journals
yeah just a quick question on the
apprenticeship and the placements at
this age group and crucified Avenue
placements from Austria
um how many were that was at 10 last
year as well
[Music]
what level are these placement students
or who have finished their placement
coming in to the organizations
opportunities
um which is absolutely fantastic for
what we do what we need as well is that
whole language they're serious that
you'll receive able to get through time
and I experiencing the goal so that's
where not just traffic that's why all
the political authorities
and it has been more experienced social
workers do really and it's very into the
agency markets and to um
just fine and finally got the point on
this then I work into expand your
placements because it sounds like really
good scheme map will help trackers in
the future as we go forward hopefully
lots will not stay on
so the Children's Services director do
have um
and you know we've got a balanced
[Music]
um
and I think we all understand why this
comments every single meeting that we
have is because of the amount of
resources that we have to pay out in
terms of agency spend and I think we all
know in this room that it's better to
have to have your own staff working here
for us and not just particularly the
reduction and the funding because
obviously it's at a high level if you're
using an agency
that it is better for this service
users quite frankly
um I think
um in in terms of the different
agencies I I don't know how many
agencies there are and I'm not sure you
know how we sort of understand
what the costs are for each agency so
now we're getting value for money and
you know it's not something that I've
explored
um you know over the years
if you've got a number of paintings then
how do you test that out in terms of
value for
money having value for service
that's one question I think
um the other issue is
the legal services
obviously it is a key part of the
authority because
you know there's a lot of issues that
deal with legal and aspects I mean
um
again I think that has been a an issue
for quite some time it seems to have
dipped quite a lot in terms of the
number of staff that we have in terms of
the legal services and that is a worry
you know
we need those
and I just wanted
why that particular person would have
happened
yeah
okay
um which is about how do we test the
quality of the agency research so
um in certain things that we can chosen
since this direction there is their
practice
and they are the center of good things
and positive so they
[Music]
um
to ensure that quality of resources
coming through is absolutely
um what we would expect to have in place
um and they have a really Global
Technologies
for example making sure that the
referencing and operations that really
really little books so
um
I think what might be a good idea
um next time in December we've possibly
government
the market is
connect me
with the body practices
Improvement please come in and perhaps
do look at the presentation offline you
know to the community just to provide
You Against Me by Assurance so that's in
the questions
face
in terms of Google services obviously
I've got my colleague and he had a legal
um
today he brought that from the agenda so
perhaps the many questions maybe
answered what's that record and has been
heard but again I guess you could do the
same thing to make sure that the
resources
produce and you've got that robust
Assurance
being perhaps called applications they
want people to repost through the job
you ensure that they have a good
induction
um I guess if they're not need to study
something like that then you know we
wouldn't continue with that supplements
services
offers
and there's nothing to do with the stage
I think there are a number of factors
um
I think along that
um for more years have been tempted Away
by the drugs that can be commanded at
working as a local employer especially
given the financial circumstances that
present themselves today I think
the difficulties have perhaps been
exacerbated by the pandemic in that the
way we work has changed significantly by
far greater offers around flexible
working and hybrid working opportunities
at which in turn have
um
presentable ways with more opportunities
from a geographical perspective and
lawyers are no longer constrained to
having necessary to work it in somewhere
that's within a reasonable commute there
are some lawyer roles which do lend
themselves to significant degrees of
remote working which I think has been a
factor I think that as
the difficulties within the service have
increased that in itself has resulted in
instability within the workforce amongst
colleagues who have become unsettled and
have their own personal reasons for
leading so I think there are a variety
of factors which makes it
increasingly difficult to try and
address with any certainty
I'm happy to answer any further
questions about when I speak to the
reports in relationship supplement which
is
which is posed okay yeah I assume that
there is a national shortage of the
world
I think that goes through
the reports it is
I think I think
the collaboration with GM is really
important and we've talked about that in
various other fields of work
and I think if we can actually get some
kind of reading on how much we pay
um